she started out her career playing the
baby boy in the famous christening scene
of The Godfather now she's a grown woman
nominated for Best Director talk about
range and he's a five-time Oscar winner
please welcome the only 64 year old man
and 32 year old woman in Hollywood not
dating each other
the Coppola Sofia and Francis Ford
Sophia I always wanted you to be part of
the family business to take us to take a
story that comes from another to keep
true to his or her vision and adapt it
into a great screenplay takes a unique
gift only a few writers possess the gift
my father speaks of was an abundance
this year some extraordinary writers
took some wonderful stories and helped
bring them to life on the movie screen
the nominees for Best Adapted Screenplay
are Robert pulcini Shari Springer Berman
for American Splendor based on the comic
book series American Splendor by Harvey
Pekar our Cancer Year by Harvey Pekar
enjoys Brandner
Braulio Mantovani for City of God based
on the novel sadati today's by paulo
lins Fran Walsh Philippa boyens and
Peter Jackson for the Lord of the Rings
The Return of the King based on the book
by Jay RR Tolkien Brian Helgeland for
Mystic River based on the novel by
Dennis Lehane Gary Ross for Seabiscuit
based on the book by Laura Hillenbrand I
have the pleasure of announcing the
Oscar goes to Fran Walsh Philippa boyens
Peter Jackson for Lord of the Rings
this is the second Academy Award tonight
for Fred Walsh and first Oscar for
Philippa boyens and director Peter
Jackson
uh okay um we grew up loving these books
we had no idea that we were gonna go
gray trying to make them into movies and
we have so many people that we we need
to thank but the first person we
absolutely must think is sir professor J
are talking without whom we wouldn't be
standing here I want to thank my parents
John and Jane boyens who gave me those
books to read my wonderful brother David
my sister Nikki my beautiful children
Callum and Phoebe and chemcam ins Barry
Osbourne Howard Shaw thank you so much
for everything that you've done for us
most of all I want to thank these two
people standing behind me thank you
thanking you line Salemba marco disky
especially for all your script support
along the way and we want to say hi to
our kids billy and katie for putting up
so much with with mum and dad working on
this film all their lives there are only
seven and eight years old and i
especially just lastly want to thank our
wonderful cast who who just got their
tongues around this rather awkward text
and made it come to life with such
emotion and passion and heart so thank
you very very much Blaine gentlemen
please welcome the Academy Award winning
couple Tim Robbins and Susan Sarandon